[Musique]
avec volée une frappe bien sûr bonjour
hélène bonjour pauline à la une de la
presse ce matin le sommet qui va réunir
à partir d'aujourd'hui vers 16h heure de
paris et jusqu'à demain les 27
dirigeants de l'union européenne à
versailles a rendez vous évidemment
dominée par la guerre en ukraine mais le
soir évoque un sommet existentielle pour
tenter d'échapper à la paralysie et
desserrer l'étau qui menacerait tout un
destin civilisationnel une réaction
salutaire selon le quotidien belge qui
regrette que la guerre apparaissent
encore une fois comme la seule à même
d'imposer des changements fondamentaux
une guerre que les européens auraient
peut-être pu éviter s'ils avaient misé
durant les deux dernières décennies sur
la société civile russe plutôt que sur
le gaz de poutine l'histoire ne se
refaisant pas à l'envers et maintenant
que la guerre est là l'europe cherche la
riposte à poutine et le figaro
s'interroge en brandissant une menace
existentielle le président russe va-t-il
faciliter l'adoption d'une boussole
stratégie commune aux européens qui
n'ont pas toujours vu le même péril à
leur porte si le on sait affiche pour le
moment son unité les dossiers sur la
table risque de la mettre à l'épreuve le
parisien/aujourd'hui en france citant
entre autres la question de l'embargo
sur les hydrocarbures russes le sort à
réserver aux réfugiés d'ukrainiens ou
encore les investissements nécessaires
pour financer la transition énergétique
la souveraineté alimentaire et bien sûr
la défense la capacité commune
effectivement des européens à se
défendre sera au coeur de ce sommet mha
europe de la défense est née 0 la croix
rappelle que les vingt-sept promettent
des moyens militaires hors du commun
avec l'allemagne notamment qui dit
vouloir consacrer désormais plus de 2%
de son pib aux dépenses militaires
autrement dit une révolution cette
décision en revanche pour le moment sur
la répartition éventuelle des rôles avec
le temps faute de consensus l'idée même
d'un renforcement des capacités
militaires européennes c'est aussi
grincer quelques dents en france
l'humanité
juge vertigineux ce basculement de l'ue
vers l'armement cette europe de la
défense promu précipitamment ne sera pas
l'outil de souveraineté politique rêvé
par certains ni une garantie de paix
prévient le journal qui assure que cette
défense commune va se construire sous la
tutelle de l'otan et renforcer la
logique des blocs et de ripostes une
politique du bras de fer militaire qui
fera le jeu de vladimir poutine selon
les mavs la russie de vladimir poutine
hélène que l'ukraine accuse d'avoir
bombardé hier un hôpital pour enfants et
une maternité marioupol mais ces images
font la une de nombreux quotidiens
européens ce matin en particulier des
quotidiens britanniques qui exprime une
émotion intense barbares dépravation le
mal a ajouté aux mâles titrent les
journaux outre manche dans le dessein de
steve kamleh qu'on a vu à l'instant les
images de cet hôpital bombardé sont
diffusés cette fois par russia today as
qui est accusée de propagande est
désormais interdite en europe la chaîne
russe livre sa version de l'histoire les
courageux soldats russes ont ciblé la
prochaine génération de néo nazis
dans un rapport mis en ligne hier
amnesty international hélèna à
documenter un autre bombardement russe
en ukraine là ça s'est passé c'était le
3 mars dernier à tchernihiv c'est au
nord de kiev 20 lors de ce bombardement
qui figurait parmi les plus meurtriers
depuis le début de l'invasion 47 morts
d'après les autorités ukrainiennes huit
bombes non guidées sont tombés sur une
petite place de la ville où la majorité
des victimes faisaient tout simplement
la queue pour acheter de la nourriture
selon le lg qui dit n'avoir pas
identifié d'objectifs militaires
légitimes à l'endroit de cette frappe ou
à proximité un possible crime de guerre
selon amnesty international qui demande
une enquête de la cour pénale
internationale
une autre enquête réalisée cette fois
par le journal le monde affirme que des
armes à sous-munitions qui sont
interdites par des traités
internationaux sont utilisées dans ce
conflit si l'origine de ces tirs et
parfois difficile à prouver certaines
images montreraient là encore une
probable responsabilité de l'armée russe
selon le journal qui a cherché à
reconstituer une zone de tir à partir de
laquelle cette section de missile
transportant des charges explosives et
retrouver à kharkiv ont pu être lancées
selon le monde cette zone de tir aurait
été située vers la russie et des zones
occupées par son armée au moment des
attaques le 27 février dernier l'armée
russe hélène qui continue de progresser
en ukraine malgré des failles dans son
offensive erreur stratégique problèmes
logistiques lacunes dans le
renseignement d'après libération poutine
patine en ukraine le journal fait état
de l'incrédulité des adversaires de la
russie face aux images de tanks embourbé
de convois enlisé de soldats hagard ça
c'est une guerre supposés éclair est en
passe de devenir un cauchemar de
dissuasion évanoui libé 1 qui rappelle
pauline née en moi que la force de
description de vladimir poutine reste
évidemment redoutable le président le
président russe qu'on va retrouver dans
ce très beau dessin de bên jennings tout
au bout d'une table interminable si loin
de ses frères humains cette fameuse
table à laquelle il avait convié entre
autres emmanuel macron au kremlin on va
revenir dans un instant sur la guerre en
ukraine etc figurent ces visages mais on
ne se quittent pas là-dessus hélène on
ne se quittent pas là dessus mais hélas
pour les fans du psg dont vous êtes
paulina n'avait pas de victoire pour les
parisiens des faits hier par le real
madrid en 8e de finale retour de la
ligue des champions 3 ha ha le cauchemar
de paris pleure le parisien aujourd'hui
en france puni par le roi l'équipe parle
bien sûr de la tête l'attaquant du real
karim benzema l'équipe qui commence à
penser que décidément kylie ann papé est
trop fort pour le psg ira-t-il
finalement rejoindre son coéquipier
l'équipe de france real telle est la
question pour le moment tout cas marca
ne boude pas son plaisir
sos madrid jeudi le quotidien sportif ça
c'est madrid voilà voilà la une de marca
je ne sais pas comment on dit il ne faut
pas vendre la peau de l'ours en espagnol
mais vous aviez raison hellène merci
beaucoup et à tout à l'heure